this coming here to hillsdale college is
an act of maturity right right and
maturity is a desirable thing it's
better in all ways than being immature
it opens up more possibilities it's not
subjugation to more constraint that's
right acceptance of a voluntary system
of disciplined striving and the opening
up of an immense vista of opportunity
if i was as good as psychology as you
are i'd trade jobs with
[Music]
hello everyone
i have the great good fortune today well
first of all to be sitting outside which
is quite nice
and also to be speaking to dr larry arn
who is president of hillsdale college
hillsdale college is a liberal arts
institution in hillsdale michigan and
it's quite a remarkable place i was
asked to deliver a commencement address
there earlier this year and went up for
the day i knew about hillsdale a little
bit but hadn't visited there it's a
remarkable island of educational sanity
in the midst of a sea of educational
chaos and i'm going to be talking today
to dr aaron who's been president of this
august institution for a number of
decades about well about hillsdale
college in general about its history
about his tenure there and his
activities and occupation
and enterprise and about the state the
dismal state let's say of the higher
education enterprise in general in the
united states and in the west more
broadly
so uh
i hope you enjoy the conversation
welcome dr orn thank you very much for
coming to see me and also for the
commencement invitation and
for
uh agreeing to do this podcast i'm
really looking forward to it well you're
a tremendous host
and a tremendous man a great pleasure
for me to be with you yeah it's been fun
it's been fun we had uh
we're out in the boat for the sunsets
and we had some fireworks at night and
it's quiet and peaceful here and away
from the fray let's say so that's been
lovely and dr arn and i have been
talking a lot about plans for
educational revival in some sense in the
future and so there'll be lots of things
coming down the pipelines on that front
but to begin with i think we'll start by
talking about hillsdale and about its
singular vision and its founding and so
why don't we start tell tell me about
how he'll tell everybody about how
hillsdale got its beginning and let's
walk through the history of the
institution
uh history starts in 1844
uh
it was on the frontier in michigan
that was
far as the country went back then uh a
bunch of new england preachers
who were classically educated they uh
they read latin and greek which means
that they knew the books that were
written before jesus
and they were very loyal to jesus and
they brought the tradition of a liberal
education with them
out to the frontier
and they founded a college and
they
met in the town hall
they just
one particular one of them and a ransom
done rode a horse into town
and there were two hotels two hotels
thriving metropolis
and
he said i would like to talk to the
leading citizens
who care about education
and a bunch of them gathered and they
use city hall
it wasn't a government thing
the college had never had any money from
the government
but city hall back then was conceived a
place where the city could use it the
citizens could use it
and they made a deal and they started
the college they uh
the city pledged
ten thousand dollars
if the
college would raise ten thousand dollars
and that came from uh
this ransom done and some other people
they went they were preachers and they
went riding around the countryside all
over wisconsin and illinois and indiana
and michigan
and uh
they'd give sermons and they'd ask for
money
and the money came two dollars and five
dollars at a time we still have the list
uh
and
what did they want to do well they were
very
clear about that the college has a very
beautiful founding document
uh it's the discovery of that that made
me think i could
uh
find a calling in managing the college
and it commits the college to four
things they are
learning freedom faith and character
and those are all drawn out of the great
tradition of the liberal arts that goes
back to medieval times indeed back to
plato's academy before that
and so they you know you you need to be
free in order to
what does the liberal arts mean it means
the study of the ultimate things the
things that are good to know just
because they're good to know and then
you need to be able to you need to have
your freedom to do that
the college has always been interested
in the constitution
uh and you need to have a strong
character you need to not be overcome by
vice but pursue virtue
and what else
and you need to and god
is a big figure so
those are the points and then you know
this is in 1844
and 16 years later the world fell apart
the civil war began in 1861
and
it's curious about that because
we didn't have any military training at
the college
but effectively all of the young men
joined the union army
and they
uh
uh there were
more than 40 of them at the battle of
the gettysburg in the peach orchard on
the second day helped to turn the tide
all in all about 500 of our students
went more than any place except yale
which is older and larger than we were
then
and
the faculty had been very involved so
why do you think these preachers that
started hillsdale christians were also
interested in the benefits of a liberal
arts education why didn't they just
agitate start a seminary
that's you know um
great political rights uh
religion is not can't can't be simply
open to philosophy
but the most open is the christian
religion
uh he he talks about the spanish names
harry harry jaffa teachement he knows
his teacher leo strauss he talks about
the fact that
moses my
embodies he's a jew and
all for
a muslim
and thomas aquinas are rough
contemporaries
and
uh
thomas aquinas could write most openly
about god about
about the truth is known by reason in
the in the great sumatheological
the first query is
whether anything apart from reason is
necessary to know god
and he
says you know that that that book a
wonderful book is written in the form of
the disputed question so here's the
question
then two or three opinions about it two
or three answers and then his own
opinion and his own opinion is
yes there are some things apart from
reason you need but you can know a heck
of a lot by reason right so there's this
alignment and reason in that sense
that's the alignment in some sense
between the greek tradition the platonic
tradition and the philosophical
tradition and the emergent christian
tradition there is an overlap there
that's really quite remarkable that
comes together with the joint
conceptualization of the logos
so because that conception of regen
reason that you're describing that's the
greek
notion of the logos and that was
adjoined oddly to the christian notion
of the logos which i think is a kind of
historical mystery but the fact that
those things actually overlaid and
overlapped is a remarkable synchronicity
we could say and so
the greeks believed that you could move
towards the good and the sum of all
goods as a consequence of logos as a
consequence of reason and then the
christians insisted that that logos had
been embodied in a particular figure and
that there were divine attributes
associated with that
and so
and so maybe that's part of what's
underlying what what's underneath the
allowance on the christian side
for the greek philosophical tradition
underneath the rubric in some sense of a
modified judaism
it's not something you'd necessarily
expect but it's definitely something
that happened and i think there's an
important thing to lay out in that
regard too because a lot of modern
people are taught that there's a real
antithesis between the religious say the
catholic in particular and education in
general and science in particular but as
i've looked into that more deeply i've
become convinced that exactly the
opposite is the case and that the
university tradition
certainly which grow to the monastic
tradition just as clearly as can be but
also the scientific tradition are deeply
embedded inside the religious substrate
rather than operating in a manner that's
antithetical and i think the fact that
the preachers preachers knew that even
in 18 well even they knew that in the
mid-1800s and that drove them to
decide that a liberal arts education
studying people like plato and aristotle
for example was actually commensurate
with a broader let's say ethical and
christian goal it's not obvious why that
would be the case to pull in these
pagans it uh so first of all
uh a prerequisite for entry to hillsdale
college in 1844 was you had to read both
greek and latin
and so they started prep school for
people who couldn't do that and you just
you'd learn those and then you could
come but the way they looked at the
world and i you know i think it's a
wonderful way to look at the world
myself is that
uh this account of logos which you bring
up
that's the greek word both for reason
and for speech
and that means that that
whatever you can
think you can say and whatever you can
say you can think
and that means that this conversation
is a kind of sharing
that no other creature is capable of
and it's a transformative process as
well a redemptive and transformative
process and that's right and and and
connected
uh aristotle writes that were uh
more gregarious it comes from the greek
word for flock
than horses or bees
right and that means and so
it's this nature of man but then
logos is not
when we talk
we can see
you know how to get from a to b
we can also think about whether to go
from a to b
and that brings in the divine because
that would be in both greek philosophy
and in the christian faith and the
jewish faith
and i think the islamic faith
uh that would be the ultimate
destination very god right that's like a
definition right if you think about this
as a mapping problem and that part of
what we're doing well dialoguing
exchanging logos is to
map out the terrain
that includes the destination and the
details of the journey all of that and
then the ultimate destination is a
destination that would be guided by the
highest good by definition right because
your destination is a good you wouldn't
be going there if you didn't think it
was better unless you're aiming down
and so the ultimate destination in some
sense is the transcendent destination
and so that's like a definition of the
divine path and in some sense a
definition of the spirit that animates
you while you're walking down that path
and then you say and i think there's an
instinctual element to this that's
associated with that gregariousness so
you know people are unbelievable mimics
right we imitate each other on a scale
that's unparalleled among other
creatures and we do that with language
but we can literally inhabit
we can almost literally inhabit each
other's bodies each other's frames of
reference and we do that by exchanging
viewpoints essentially and so we're
negotiating together this pathway to the
highest possible point and i think
that's marked so you know what i was
hoping when we started this discussion
like i always hope with my podcast is
that we would fall into a discussion and
be engaged by it right and then it would
be animated by a spirit that was its own
not instrumental not planned but
something that would emerge
automatically as a consequence of
goodwill and honest communication and
what's so fuc fascinating about that
literally is that if that happens it's
intrinsically and instinctually engaging
right you feel the conversation as
meaningful
and that's a marker as far as i can tell
for the manifestation of that logos that
instinct for meaning it's not something
rational it's way it's it's the thing
upon which rational discourse
fundamentally depends and maybe the goal
of rational discourse and then you could
also think this is a wonderful way of
thinking about it too you know is that
if you're listening to a symphony
in some sense
you're
apprehending its completion right so
there's a voyage to the end
but
getting to the end of the symphony is
not the purpose of
listening to the music
even though you know that end is there
so you have the end in mind but if the
end is
appropriate then the journey is
becomes intrinsically meaningful in and
of itself and so you get the destination
tied to the journey in that intrinsic
sense and i do believe that people
experience that as deep engagement and
meaning
and so and that's the purpose of
dialogue and the there's that christian
idea that goes along with that too and
it's an idea certainly that
the therapists have picked up on is that
that redempt that dialogue honest
dialogue is genuinely spiritually
redemptive
we'll get back to more with larry yarn
in just a moment first we'd like to
thank our sponsor shopify designed for
anyone to sell anywhere shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business an all-in-one
e-commerce platform shopify helps
business owners achieve independence by
making it easier to start run and grow
your online storefront shopify reduces
the barriers to business ownership by
making good e-commerce more accessible
and intuitive shopify helps you to find
customers and drive sales wherever you
are online market your business with
built-in tools for creation execution
and analysis manage orders shipping and
payments and gain the insights you need
to scale your business dedicated to
empowering independent business owners
everywhere millions of successful brands
trust shopify to sell ship and process
payments anywhere get started by
building and customizing your online
store no coding or design experience
required go to shopify.com
jbp for a free 14-day trial and get full
access to shopify's entire suite of
features start selling on shopify today
go to shopify.com
jbp right now that's shopify.com
that seems to be so i jbp all all that
you just said is breathtakingly good
and it shows you understand what
teaching is today
we think of teaching is doing something
to somebody
right it's not it's doing something with
somebody
uh plato writes a letter he wrote 13
letters but one of them apparently is
his the seventh and he says how would
you capture the teaching of socrates
it's just in these conversations
and so he invented the dialogue
for that purpose and then his student
aristotle invented the dialectical
treatise
where they
introduce a thing and you talk about it
a while and you have to go back over and
something else comes up
so it's like a conversation
and the point is
we learn together
talking and thinking are the same
thing yeah that's why free speech is so
you think well
why think well so that you think before
you act why think before you act
so you don't fall into a pit how do you
think you think dialogically even if
you're thinking only internally what
that means is you've trained yourself to
be more than one person at the same time
very difficult thing to manage most of
the time we think through dialogue and
it's so interesting to me too that these
long-form podcasts have become a
cultural phenomenon right because in
some sense people like rogan in
particular pioneered this these
long-form dialogues
in some real sense that is a return to
that platonic tradition of dialectical
learning and it and part of the reason
that people like these podcasts as well
isn't because necessarily because of the
content although that's relevant but
this is also relevant to the teaching
enterprise it's because they love to see
the process of dialogue modeled
and so a lot of the comments on the
youtube channels like had a conversation
with my father and i put it up on my
channel i interviewed him about his life
and i wanted to do that personally i had
my reasons but it turned out to be a
very popular podcast much more than i
had expected it to be and
i don't think it was because the content
per se was
like universally fascinating you know it
was the details of my father's life in a
particular time and place in northern
saskatchewan when he was growing up
really on the frontier
but
people really like to see the genuine
interjection intergenerational dialogue
modeled
and we have no idea how important an
element of education that is right is
that because as a professor partly what
you're doing is inculcating knowledge
which is doing something to someone
let's say but a huge part of it is
modeling the process by which knowledge
itself is generated and expanded
so uh
one can understand
aristotle by reading the first lines
the first line of the metaphysics is the
human being stretches himself out to
know
we want to know
and so your father
anybody talking with his father is a
demonstration
how one generation affects the next but
your father you're a remarkable man and
people wonder
where does that guy come from
and so to find out that information
and then to find out that it's uh normal
you know you weren't
your father was not
a professor at cambridge right uh your
father was
a normal man and a heck of a man that's
a normal man is a fine thing to be just
think of the conclusion you can draw
about the form of government of
aristocracy
right
it is one of the most worthy forms of
government
but is also fatally flawed
because
sons are not necessarily like their
fathers and daughters like their mothers
and fathers so that you see in other
words
there's a there's an account of how
nature works
and hearing you talk to your father
and it's
hearing a lecture about it
is different right because yeah there's
they're seeing the look if you're
talking to your dad
they're seeing the raw material
and uh we've been talking a lot the last
couple days and your dad comes up a lot
there's a couple of things i realized
about him i thought about this for a
long time so my father has a very large
collection of single shot rifles 300 of
them or something like a lot and he's
been i would say compelled and obsessed
by collecting them learning about them
and becoming an expert marksman because
he he was and he is an expert marksman
he was competing at provincial levels so
very good marksman and when he hunted he
hunted with single shot rifles because
the goal was to hit the target with one
shot
and it it really i wasn't interested in
rifles the same way he was and he had a
craftsman interest in them too because
he made gun stocks and he was a good
good carpenter and handyman um very
artistically gifted and very precise in
his
in his uh in his
in his workings his grandfather who
raised him was a blacksmith who could
make virtually anything out of nothing
and so
but his his his preoccupation with guns
a mystery to me because i didn't share
the same thing temperamentally you know
i was probably too tender hearted to be
uh to be a hunter
but i it came to me at one point after
having meditated on this for a long time
that the reason my dad was so interested
in rifles was because
he wanted to hit the target with a
single shot and he realized that that
was the purpose of life
and i knew at that point that the word
sin was a derivation it's also derived
through uh the jewish equivalent of the
word sin the hamartia which is the greek
word means to miss the target it's an
archery term and the jewish equivalent
of the word for sin has the same kind of
derivation it means to miss the target
and so i thought oh i see what my dad
was doing he didn't know this either is
he was practicing to
to aim in the most deadly possible
manner one shot dead center of the right
target and all of that perfectionism
that goes along with mechanical
machining let's say and the precision
that's necessary to make a rifle it's
all associated with that hunting
tradition that characterizes human
beings so deeply like i mean our our
whole physical platform is a throwing
platform and we aim at everything all
our sports are aims at targets it's
really deeply embedded inside of me of
of us and so i realized that about my
father i told him that i said i think i
figured out why you're so interested in
rifles and shooting so i outlined that
he said yeah i think that's right he
didn't know that
and then
so that was very interesting that
precision element of him but also
one of the things that my father gave me
as a gift and i think my mother did this
as well is that he was really 100
behind me the best in me i always knew
even when i was a little kid that
he had
he didn't have my back exactly
he was a firm supporter of
the best being made manifest in me
and many of my friends didn't have that
with their fathers and of course people
who lack fathers entirely unless they're
very fortunate often don't have that at
all and so my dad spent a lot of time
with me when i was a very little kid
teaching me to read
and hours
a day when he came home from work for
months on end and i became an expert
reader because of that and that was
unbelievable
unbelievable gift and the time he spent
that was just the fact that he taught me
how to do it because he was a
schoolteacher but that he spent all that
time and valued it so intently it gave
me this deep
rooted
admiration and love for literacy that
was
maybe that's the the most fundamental
element of my existence i suppose it's
that that love but i know that
having that male encouragement
firmly on the side of the promotion of
your development that is something
that's just of inestimable importance
and something of course that should be
offered by teachers to their students
male or female alike
if uh you know there's
you hear stories i guess it happens that
uh parents want to dominate their kids
fathers might want the kid to be like
them right
and that's not the natural thing the
natural thing is you think
one of the contributions i a parent can
make in my life
is for
my children
to have benefits i didn't have
and to have character better than mine
and that's you know that is
fundamental to the teaching business
i i think uh
today in the teaching business
if you
in all of it right you know so i i'm a
teacher at hillsdale college i'm the
president but i'm a teacher too
and
we think today if you read about it
we want them
to think something
we want them to we want to do something
to them to make them the way we want
but that violates the spirit of the
dialogue that you just that you brought
up earlier right in other words that's
conversion therapy that's what that is
that is that is what it is and and and
we're gonna so
i'm we're gonna set up a system to work
on you
and then what you know and what you are
will be a product of our work
and that is
the most uncharitable approach to
education
and it's dominating these days yeah well
it's not education it's ideological
inculcation it's propaganda it kind of
reminds me of the prussian education
model and you know a lot of that was was
the foundation the philosophical
foundation of the american public
education system one of the things that
was a mystery to me i built this program
a long while back called self-authoring
and there's an element of that future
authoring that helps people walk through
the process of developing a personal vis
vision
and so first of all people are asked to
envision what their life could be like
five years down the road if they had
what they needed and wanted in a manner
that would be best for them if they were
taking care of themselves right so
imagine that you're worthwhile
now you get to have what you need and
want but you have to aim at it and so
you ask yourself what would that be if i
could have it and so that's the first
part of the exercise and then the next
part
steps you through seven major
components of your life
your education your career your intimate
relationship your family your physical
health etc
major sub components of your life asking
you to detail out a vision for each of
those and then to make a relatively
concretized plan
and then to outline a vision of hell
which is where you might end up if you
let your bad habits
carry you away
so i used this in my classes and we did
a bunch of
research with it as well showing that it
decreased the probability that students
would drop out of college by about 50
percent which is stunning
it's stunning and what's even more
stunning is no universities have picked
it up but in any case
one of the things that really struck me
as a mystery after that i started using
in my classes
was okay why the hell do we have an
education system where kids are taught
for 12 years minimum if they graduate
from high school and never once do we
sit them down and say
all right you could be who you wanted to
be in the best of all possible
ways
but you have to know what that would be
and then you have to aim at it even no
matter how imperfectly right you have to
start to flesh out that vision why don't
we do that
i thought well that's such an oversight
how can we have structured an entire
education system where
we spend 12 years doing everything
except the one thing that we should
clearly do which is to help students
elucidate a vision for the development
of their character which is what
hillsdale concentrates on and then i i
did some background historical
investigation and found out that the
american public school system and then
public school systems in general japan
throughout europe were based on the
prussian military model
and so the american idea was that when
the rural types were flooding into the
cities in the midst of the high end of
the industrial revolution that there was
going to be a demand for
disciplined workers
and so the prussian governmental
authorities wanted to produce
surf-like soldiers who were nothing but
obedient and so the prussian education
model first state education system was
adopted in the u.s and then broadly in
the west and the underlying ethos was
will produce obedient soldiers and then
bet workers obedient same thing
inculcation of a of an ideological uh
uh mode of life right and so
that's what we have for an education
system and then i would say that ethos
to a large degree spread up into the
higher education systems too and so now
we have a situation where
well you know the proper thing to do
with students is to train them to be
activists social justice warriors and
people who are
saving the planet in a in a particular
ideologically riddled manner without
this
dialogical exploration that's actually
the basis of true education which is by
the way where we're talking about
hillsdale today
so yeah see that uh
i
i realize now why they won't use the
self-authoring program which we will at
hillsdale college
the point is
if they arrive
and you think the purpose is to do
something to them
then you're not as interested in what
they want to do
and and yet
and you know
uh i think
it's you know the the only rule that
works in a college in my opinion is be
good
you know there are a few details too but
you know
is that a good thing to do don't do it
if it's not you know and and
so
you want to teach them
to be good human beings excellent human
beings
but most of the work is in them
i told you a story uh uh when i came to
hillsdale college about 25 of the
freshmen
left at the end of the freshman year
and that means that at least one in four
are dissatisfied and that changes
everything now
25 is a very good number
you know because it's more like 50 or 60
percent that's right
but especially among young men
but it's but it's
you know
my my favorite
uh activity is eating in the dining hall
with the students which i've been doing
now for 22 years
and it's delightful
and you know they soon forget who you
are and you just have a talk
and i discovered doing that that a lot
of them were angry with the college
and and why were they it took a long
time for me to figure this out but
uh the summary of the of the arguments
was i finally found a phrase that
explained it to me
nobody told me
nobody told me about this nobody told me
about that about what sort of things and
when was this this is in the year 2000
2002 the breakthrough came in 2002
and and and you know like we're very
old-fashioned college
we have the sexes are separated in the
dormitories
and there's no drinking in the
dormitories and all that
and so you know and that's in the
curriculum anti-animal house institution
it is very much you know and and uh and
and
uh
the curriculum
is one half of the curriculum is the
same for every student you know because
there's we we argue they're great things
to know
and you have to be introduced to them
all of them
and
you figure out your major sure
but you won't be able to practice your
major if you go into a particular line
of work unless you know something about
the world as it's so anyway we so that's
all very strict and
it was stricter now but it was strict
when i came there somewhat
well
i finally got to the bottom of it
they
have to agree
you can't be doing things to people
unless they agree that you may do it
right policy policy that involves
compulsion is by definition bad policy
it is isn't it though and yeah you have
to spend all the time enforcing it and
you produce resistances and so so your
students were telling you 25 of them
that they didn't feel that they had
entered into this agreement on a
sufficiently informed and voluntary
basis that's right and that and i was
missing that i thought they had a
disagreement with me
about whether they ought to be having
sex before they get married
and they may have that disagreement but
that wasn't the operative one
the operative one was
nobody told me
and and so we
when i saw that
it was a revelation in a dinner with a
bunch of frat boys
uh
who i i saw what the rub was
and the next morning we wrote the honor
code and now we don't lose one percent
of our students from from yeah so we
need to say that again so your dropout
rate is what
uh after freshman year one percent one
percent compared to sixty percent well
it's afraid of forty percent no
yeah compared to
what was you know
forty percent right right and what's the
average for institutions
it's more than no i'm scared i messed up
my number that's okay ours was 20
and the the run
in colleges generally is around 40 40 to
45.
and and so
and you know 20 is huge by the way it
means every time you sit down at the
table
there's a couple of people who are
unhappy right right and you don't want
that you want because college means
partnership
it's so strange that you have this
strict and traditionalist college
but aligned with that is an
ethos of self-determination and
self-development and so it's a very
paradoxical paradoxical juxtaposition of
of order and opportunity and an
interesting one because people this is i
think part of the downfall of an
excessive protestantism in some sense is
that and and it's also a downfall of
small liberal philosophy is that we tend
to think of all external constraints as
inhibitions on
self-actualization right it's just
limits it's just arbitrary walls that
you're running into to stop the
flowering of the wonder that is you but
it's a very perverse way of
conceptualizing opportunity because
it does turn out that under many
circumstances
if you accept a strict regimen of a
priory rules like in a chess game that
what that does is open up a wealth of
opportunities to you that you wouldn't
have otherwise had so there's this weird
relationship between strict rules and
freedom and
one of the things that i love though is
why we're having this conversation too
is when i went to hillsdale i've been to
lots of university campuses in my life
and many in the more recent years and
they're generally per
there's a sense of resentment entitled
resentment that permeates the
establishment you see that the faculty
the administrators and most of all in
the students
and it's very unsettling and
uncomfortable
and uh i really felt the absence of that
at hillsdale talking to all the students
talking to the faculty talking to the
administrators there was a harmony there
like a musical harmony and i know your
campus is also uh
one-third of the students are involved
in the music program in 70
right 440. yeah it's amazing and there
was music everywhere in the campus which
i thought was just wonderful and so
and it's also so interesting to hear you
talk about this old-fashioned approach
with sex-segregated dormitories and so
forth and these 1950s rules or before
that let's say and that
students actually find that acceptable
if they're brought on voluntarily so
let's talk about that honor code more so
why did you decide
that the solution to the problem of
their discomfort wasn't alteration of
the rules it was more clear explication
of the a priory rules why did you go
that route and why do you think it what
was the route and why did it work
what i thought before i had this
revelation
just quickly how how'd i have it
a national class long jumper a very
beautiful young man a frat
boy began senior dinner they come over
to
our house and we have dinner with them
you know and and this was a senior
dinner
and he began by forgiving me
for the rules
and
you know and i was cranky that night
and i said
why did you come here
and
he loved it he said i said what what do
you love about it
you want us to be this the same as the
university of michigan you should and
then i said the golden thing i said
could you read when you came here
and he said yes and i said did you
because if you'd read you'd know
and how can you be complaining about it
four years later
and i just noticed
i had the moral high ground
and in the end it wasn't really the
particular rules
if you had
the most libertine rules in the world
there'd be plenty of people who'd object
to that right right right it's that
their will
had been consulted
and so right and that was made
thoroughly explicit and understood
that's what the honor trick that's what
the honor code does and see
we were afraid of the honor code
uh
because we weren't very strong in
applications we're very strong now
and afraid we wouldn't get enough and
what if they don't come
yeah that's the same sort of fear that's
uh i would say paralyzed and castrated
let's say the catholic church
and it's liberalization it's well we're
making it too difficult for people we
just have to make it easier we make it
easy enough then everyone will come i
read kierkegaard you know and
kierkegaard has a famous passage where
he describes just how useless an idler
he really is and how it's impossible for
him to be a benefactor of the industrial
age and to make everything that's
already been made easy even easier for
people and so that his signal
contribution was to do everything he
could to make things more difficult
because there would come a time when
everything had become so easy that the
cry for something difficult would become
overwhelming
and and i love that and that's a good
example of the necessity of these of
these that's an excellent rule of thumb
when dealing with the young
because
what is their drive
they're like you know i think of them
like plants i think they grow i don't
think you're making them into anything i
think they grow
and you can stunt them though you can't
do that oh boy can't you though and so
they want to grow
they they they they don't even fully
understand the process
but
they want to grow up
it's the reason why
a one-year-old
or a three-year-old probably
will get cranky
if the five-year-old is taught is is
treated like more of an adult
right right they want to grow up
right and so
you have to harness that
uh you know it's not really even a
harness
uh you have to get that on your side
uh and that means encourage you and that
means
this coming here to hillsdale college is
an act of maturity right right and
maturity is a desirable thing it's
better in all ways than being immature
it opens up more possibilities it's not
subjugation to more constraint that's
right acceptance of a voluntary system
of discipline striving and the opening
up of an immense vista of opportunity
yeah
if i was as good as psychology as you
are i'd trade jobs with you
if uh
it's uh yeah see that and you know i
i'll just tell you
when you approach it like that
happiness blossoms everywhere
i mean hillsdale college
i used to sit down in the dining hall
and lunchtime in the dining hall is
come to visit hillsdale college i'll
take you to the dining hall we'll have
lunch
and you sit down with these kids i'm the
only old guy who sits with the kids all
the time
and
it's delightful it wasn't always
they had complaints
you know and i would i would leave the
table thinking
we're subsidizing the daily
daylights out of these kids and they're
not happy
what are we spending our money for
and and you know it's still very
perverse and strange that what you
decided to do was to implement an honor
code so first of all why honor why that
archaic and old-fashioned word and maybe
we could walk through what the code is
and how you introduce that to students
and and then why they not only appear to
accept it but to accept it so
assiduously that they all stay in the
college which is that's an amazing
achievement right that's that's
remarkable and very unlikely achievement
so and it's such a strange route to get
there yeah so so let so why an honor
code well honor so uh you know i have
devices reading aristotle and teaching
aristotle and
that's always good for one in my opinion
and so what you learn about honor honor
is you know a great thing right it's you
know to be honorable to commit a great
act of honor right
you find out that honor is not the
highest good you find out soon
because honor depends on other people's
opinions
and a much higher in fact the highest
human relationship is friendship
uh but you can't start with friendship
honor does have the advantage of being
civic in its nature
it's something that we adopt together
and win respect from each other it's
sort of like identity in its real sense
that's right that's right honorable
identity so
and we agree what that is what the code
says is um
a hillsdale college student is honest uh
in word indeed respectful
of the rights of others
dutiful in study and service and through
education the student rises to
self-government
right right rises to self-government
right and so it's an apprenticeship with
mastery as the goal that's it and then
and you know and see commencement is the
culminating ceremony you gave one of the
best commencement speeches i've ever
heard and i've heard of past 11.
and and that is the annual
signification
that the college has done its work and
when i say the college the college the
word means partnership it means
everybody in the room
and you know there were close to 6 000
people at commencement when you spoke
and who were those people they were the
people who had made it happen
they were the students and the faculty
they were the parents
uh they were the friends of the college
uh and and they are they're they're all
there in an official capacity
we have come together to do this thing
and it had to produce these remarkable
young people that's right no to not to
produce to see there's that bloody word
again yeah yeah factory word to
encourage the development
of these remarkable young people to have
had the privilege of encouraging the
development of these young people that's
it right yeah you know if you if you
just think
uh so i i know a lot about winston
churchill because
if you know about him
i i argue you will come to love him
and i did and and
people always say to me
what explains winston
churchill well the only possible answer
to that is god and winston churchill
uh winston churchill was relatively well
born
you know winston churchill was very
smart had a tremendous memory
but you know there's
millions of people who have those
qualities
and every one of them is different from
him and every one of them is different
from each other
and that means you know you
you
you are to some extent the maker of
yourself
uh
that's a beautiful doctrine in aristotle
and so in education
know the first thing you just need to
know two things when you admit them
you need to you need to know that they
want to
and you need to know that they can
willing and able
after that
they're going to do the work and you're
going to help them
they have to agree on what the work is
because remember it's yeah so how do you
how do you make the honor code
not just
a pro forma document that's empty words
what is it because you there might there
must be specific things you do with the
honor code that bring it to life
yeah well we're governed by it and okay
so so
it is actually the ethos of the
institution so that's right there's a
there's a congruence there but you you
talk to the students when they first
come to the college
yeah and so and i understand that that's
part of the transmission of the honor
code
yeah they get i i they get it after
they're admitted first of all if you
look at admissions materials from
hillsdale college
the honor code is featured in them
and that means that we're giving you the
information from the first step
that this place is like this
and if you want it you know you'll have
a hard time finding an alternative and
if you don't want it the world is your
oyster because they're different or most
of them are different
so you start with that but then
then
along about the first of june after the
class is formed and the deposits are in
i send them a letter
it's a page and a half letter
and it's
says here's the honor code
it's a serious commitment
you should read it carefully
uh
if you think that you might not be
willing to sign it
you should tell us now
we'll help you find some place to go to
college
uh it tells them that on the monday
after you arrive on sunday for freshman
convocation
we will have a talk me and the senior
class about this document
and then you will sign it
all together or go home and uh that's
and you know i i have signed it see and
so we've all
we've all made oath
to be committed to hillsdale college now
one of the things that happens when you
do it like that
is that enforcement
becomes much less important right well
that's also the sign of good policy
right yeah i mean piaget the
developmental psychologist he was very
interested in
laying out the rational grounds for the
emergence of a moral system
and so one of his propositions which i
love is that
a goal-oriented system established on
consensual grounds will out-compete a
goal-oriented system same goal on
on grounds of compulsion
not least because the system that
requires compulsion will waste time and
resources in the enforcement so it's a
priority less efficient
and then you can add to that the fact
that
most positive human emotion and so
that's the emotion that literally makes
you enthusiastic which is to be filled
with the spirit of god because that's
what enthusiasm means right
is that you experience the positive
emotion that propels you forward in
relationship to a goal and the goal has
to be
established voluntarily or the positive
emotion systems won't kick in
so if you use compulsion
not only do you waste time and resources
on enforcement but you don't harness the
most fundamental motivational systems
and those are so fundamental by the way
that the drugs that people abuse cocaine
perhaps foremost among them in terms of
its
instantaneously attractive and addictive
qualities
cocaine directly activates that positive
emotion system which is why people love
it and so
because it's an analog of purposeful
goal directed activity and if you
establish a high goal the higher the
goal
the more rewarding
in the technical sense every step
towards that goal is but that has to all
be done voluntarily because otherwise
it's an imposition and entirely
different psychophysiological systems
come into play
we'll have more with larry yarn in just
a minute but first i want to tell you
about helix sleep
getting a good night's sleep is one of
the most important things you can do for
your health that's why helix sleep
provides tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences now me i'm
a side sleeper helix has side sleeper
models with memory foam layers for
optimal pressure relief let's say you're
a stomach or back sleeper helix has
models for you too with a more
responsive foam to cradle and support
your body and you've got to love the
enhanced cooling features to keep you
from overheating at night
every helix mattress has a hybrid design
combining individually wrapped steel
coils in the base with premium foam
layers on top for the perfect
combination of comfort and support
get started with the helix sleep quiz
and find your perfect mattress in under
two minutes
plus right now helix sleep is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows at helix sleep dot com
slash jordan that's helix sleep.com
jordan for 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows helix mattress
ships straight to your door free of
charge try it for a hundred nights
risk-free what do you got to lose go to
helixsleep.com jordan now
so here's a winston churchill
it is at once the safeguard and the
glory of mankind that it is easy to lead
and hard to drive
and that's uh when i was hired for this
job there was an mba fine man on the
committee and you can spot them a mile
away they ask nba questions
and uh if you have to drive you're not
leading that's right tyrant yeah and
you're and and they
uh he churchill believed by the way that
particular thing he says that in the
context of
how the implausible thing could happen
that britain could defeat adolf hitler
and that's why
and they they
right people hate that
and and you know so if you want and you
know if i i've
i've become experienced and stubborn now
i don't like to be in a relationship
where i'm telling anybody what to do if
they don't want to do it
well you know i really learned this as a
psychotherapist and this is partly why
i've been so upset with these
anti-conversion laws lately it's like
in a therapeutic conversation
which is any genuine conversation by the
way any genuine dialogue
you need humility
and the humility is something like
this person that i'm talking to is
actually different than me
they're different in their
pre
suppositions they're different in their
knowledge and they're different in their
destiny
and they're importantly and vitally
different in that because i think that
each person plays a signal role
in
manifesting or failing to manifest part
of the reality that moves us towards
paradise let's say in some fundamental
sense everyone has a signal role to play
in that that's part of the destiny of
their soul and you are not to interfere
with that
because you don't know
and so in a therapeutic conversation
about identity so now for example
therapists are required to affirm the
identity of their clients the gender
identity but more broadly to affirm it
and that's never the role of a
conversation
the role of a therapeutic conversation
is always to inquire about identity but
in the spirit of humilities right like
you and i have been trying to work out a
working relationship over the last
couple of days and also with stephen
blackwood down at ralston and one of the
guiding principles of our attempts to do
that isn't
that i want something from you or that
you want something from me and i think
it's partly because both of us know that
we don't necessarily know
what we want or should want from each
other but that if goodwill prevails and
if we're both aiming up in the highest
sense that we could mutually discover
the pathway forward that would be
not only mutually beneficial for us in a
sense that's way transcends the merely
instrumental but potentially benefit
beneficial for the movement towards that
higher good and that is i think in some
real sense the foundation of a of the
most genuine friendships right because
in a genuine friendship
yeah you want the best for the other
person as well as yourself but in
aristotle friendship is the highest
human association and there are three
kinds
in one kind it's
transactional
commercial friendships are often like
that
you know that's why
somebody who sells you
wood
might send you christmas candy right
right right uh
and then another kind is pleasure
aristotle's that's higher aristotle says
the young are particularly given to that
their bodies are really great and
getting better all the time
and then there's this ultimate kind and
that's the rarest and it's the permanent
kind and the permanent kind is
a shared love of something
ultimate
and a commitment to pursue it
and that's
that's that's the only map you can have
in a relationship
that's likely to sustain it
and see i've discovered and you get the
additional benefit there of not only
the
hypothetical movement towards that goal
but the deep engagement and pleasure
that accompanies each step along the way
to that goal
and that's a good marker for the quality
of the relationship right it's that it's
interesting in and of itself that's it
for its own sake so
in uh book 10 of the ethics uh
he describes this beautiful activity
and that is and you have to you have to
become
you have to get the moral virtues first
you have to be courageous and you have
to be moderate you have to be just and
you have to be
uh what and you have to be
[Music]
wise
prudent practically wise you have to be
able to
manage your life you have to be able to
control your passions you have to and it
goes beyond controlling them too
it means an act of love for the right
thing
right yeah well that i'm just going to
interrupt very briefly that's a
distinction between a freudian view of
emotion regulation and a piagetian view
because the freudians this is one of
freud's signal errors
it makes him a protestant of sorts i
would say and a liberal of sorts is that
the regulation of aggression and
sexuality is held to be a consequence in
some sense of compulsion that's the
superego so that's like the internal
tyrant saying no to aggression and no to
sexuality but the piagetian view which
is much more subtle and appropriate is
that
those
impulses are not inhibited they are
integrated into a higher mode of being
and so and so jung carried on this idea
with his idea of the integration of the
shadow and so for freud in some sense
aggression was inhibited by the superego
right you need to be aggressive
aggressive you want to be aggressive and
but the society imposes a limit on you
that's essentially a form of compulsion
but for jung with for example without
the idea of the integration of both the
shadow and the anima or the animus which
would be the contra sexual tendency it's
a matter of bringing the devil in in
some sense to play
it's like well you need that aggression
you absolutely 100 need it one of the
things that struck me about you when i
when we first met which i really liked
was that you were someone who was
capable of saying no
and i know what no means because i
thought about it a lot partly because i
was interested in childhood development
no means
if you keep doing that around me
something you do not like will
absolutely 100 percent certainly happen
to you
and you have to be willing to enforce
that or you can't say no
if you can say no you almost never have
to enforce it but you can't say no also
without the integration of that shadow
and so it isn't that aggression is
inhibited it's that it's integrated into
a higher order game this is really
relevant for aggressive young men
because they're competitive you say well
we have to socialize them to be more
like little girls which is like the
idiot plan of a multitude of
psychologists and social workers it's
like no you don't you have to
you have to
integrate that competitive impulse
towards a much higher end and then that
capacity for aggression starts to become
unstoppability and implacability and the
ability to stalwart and noble and to
abide by a code of honor let's say
so a much a much more optimistic way of
viewing yeah well and see
that energy
uh you know i'm heavily under the
influence
of the greeks and the christians and um
and the americans because the founders
of america are really great too
um
if
the point is
your motive action
everything that has a soul
you said uh
you said some form of the word animation
or animal about freud
that just means
it moves itself anything that's an
animal moves itself and that's the the
latin word for soul anima yeah and uh
and so
we move ourselves
and the point is by nature
we can
and that means we want to
and so
the question is toward what do we move
right that is the question and you know
reckless little boys
uh
you know i was one myself
uh lord knows what they'll do right
but harness that
to some high cause
and first of all
you make their life meaningful
like uh
we don't want our students tearing up
our campus over political causes
we're very conservative college we have
fame for that you know we publish a
newsletter to six and a half million
people but we don't talk about the stuff
public policy very much on the campus
and we discourage it
because why because
they're young and ignorant and they get
a chance to learn a lot and then they
can figure out what to do with the world
right right and the and and you know
it happens often because you know kids
who come to hillsdale college in a good
college they're ambitious
and uh so they want to you know this and
this and then yeah they're looking to
they're looking to take their place in a
meaningful way at the table in an
important sense and they're eager to get
on with that
so so it's no use saying
you got to wait
you just show them the place at the
table that's available to them now
and that place by the way is difficult
very very challenging you know
you want to learn uh
a bunch of boys
and girls mostly boys though
i i don't think that a constitutional
convention is a good idea and you know a
lot of people in my line of work and my
political persuasion do
and so a bunch of kids get debating me
one time
but you know because they know that i'm
against it and some other famous people
i'm not famous but they are
are for it
and they want to get up a debate
i want me to debate these people
and them
and i said okay i'll do that
i said uh
the stipulation is that you not spend
very much time on this
and they said why not it'll be fun i
said yeah maybe
i said but
uh you're not ready
to define for me the meaning of the term
politics
which is not an easy word to define it's
a form of human community that takes its
nature
from specific things about the human
being that are unique to the human being
right
and so i said and until you can do that
i don't want you you're wasting your
time
figuring out about this arcane point
about the constitution
and you know do you do you want to be
just another policy wonk
or do you want to be a learned person
and they you know and and do you and
have you noticed that there's actually a
difference between those two things and
it's an important difference and see it
calms them down you see because and
you're what you what you said see
uh
how many come for you come to you for
counseling uh i guess i'm doing that
right now
mutual
uh
it's usually a great idea
to suggest something better
than the bad thing they want
you know if it's bad and it might
usually not bad just not bad right not
good right now
and that in other words
you stoke their ambitions
because that's the fuel
that makes them go
and now you know well and what a dismal
proposition it is to set forth to a
young person who's 18 and say well your
axiomatic a priori political convictions
shallow and unmoored though they are
unabatted by any apprenticeship or
knowledge are sufficient for you to go
out and transform the world right now
like how what a dismal view that is and
and instead you can say look if you
applied yourself with all due diligence
for like 10 years in every direction you
could possibly manage you might be ready
to set a tentative toe out on the world
stage in whatever manner you could have
earned by that point
you know he
the greatness of and see that's another
thing
if you can teach somebody
you know the highest human activity in
aristotle is
uh
a secular version of the highest human
activity in
christianity or any religion
communion with god
and that's contemplation is called in
the ethnic way in ethics and it's hard
to get your soul to a state to be able
to do that you have to be courageous
you have to me you know aerosol says
if you're afraid of the bees buzzing
around you you will not be capable of
this see it requires all the virtues and
years of work right
and and if you get it
and it's an immediate beholding he says
and you don't think about anything else
at the time
and then he says
no other nothing can help you with this
except a friend
that's the highest kind of friendship
you do that with people right you see
something beautiful well that's what you
have when you have a friend is the
person there's something that they see
in you
if they're your friend that they
love and want to nurture and cherish
that's it and
they aim at precisely that and maybe
they're even better at doing that for
you than you are
for you
and and that they are for them
so a friend in that sense is in some
sense the best ally i had a friend
university morgan abbott is his name
tough guy
from a rough background poor background
he lived in a in a
he was poor in a serious way northern
alberta rural poor that's frontier level
poor man his dad was a longshoreman
he's a tough kid this morgan abbott and
he's worked with the worst delinquents
in canada for like 20 years and then
worked with brain damaged people and
he's a tough guy
he was a good friend of mine when i went
to college he was older than me came
back working in the lead smelters in
british columbia and then came back to
college to get himself educated
and
he's the person who really talked me out
of my initial socialism
and not politically
he just said something like
there's a hell of a lot more to the
world that is income encapsulated in the
socialist philosophy and he said you
know most people join the socialist
political parties to
get out of the working class by adopting
a leadership position which i liked a
lot and was commensurate with my
experience and he was a very
uh
what would you say he was a
inspiring figure for me probably more
for me even than for himself i would say
in some sense and uh
last year
two years ago when i was unbelievably
ill
him and i have kept in contact over the
years you know less intensely than we
had but in contact
and uh
he walked
five to twelve miles with me for almost
a year every single day
yeah
see
now that's
uh
if you study the greeks properly
you learn to love the word beauty
because
beauty is the perfection of good
and and so
what you just said
that was a beautiful thing
it was you know to know that a thing
like that happened
is worthy
and worthy making to everyone who hears
it
and so
the education of the young
is
it involves
helping them understand how much they
want that
everybody wants that and how noble it is
to want that yeah that's right and and
that's
so
and and see if you can get that through
to them
and you can by the way because they're
made to know it
you know well and then college also
offers that stellar opportunity i mean
when i went from my little town
my my pack of narrative well friends
there
um
a few of us went off to college not very
many
then i had this opportunity to shed who
i was
and to find a new peer group and to
become someone else in a radical way and
to do that to some degree voluntarily
right to pick a new set of people that i
wanted to associate with to pick a new
peer group some of whom were
the great thinkers of the past right
because that's one thing college offers
you the opportunity to do is to pick
a peer group in some sense that's the
great figures of the past it's a
daunting endeavor but that's what's
there before you and so
it is definitely the case that that's a
stellar opportunity and a signal
contribution of educational
establishments something difficult to
replicate online too so you open the
door for students to do that and say
this is what you should be doing at that
point a stellar group of peers who will
ennoble you as you move forward and a
shared goal of of apprenticeship and
maturation and the opportunity to take
your place at the table as an adult a
great st a great adventure all of that
yeah and that's
and you know you
you don't want to take the magic out of
it it's it's uh it's not
working on them
is mostly them working and you work with
them
and it's so fun when you get it right
you know it uh
uh and and you know we have because
we're trying in my opinion these days
and this is mostly because of changes in
philosophy that go back
400 years
we're trying to re-engineer the society
all the time
and that means you have to re-engineer
the people in it
and that means school becomes
that's its purpose
we're you're going to come here and
we're going to do things to you
right why is that an attractive
proposition
it's attractive if you want to be a
slave that's it that's it and so the
truth is
uh
like
the best teachers
i know a kindergartner garden teacher
who does this and i know many at the
college where i work who do this
in the first 10 minutes of class
there's
tingling anticipation
and
and there are two kinds of
best teachers at hillsdale one kind just
says
this is going to be great
the other kind says this is going to be
great and this is going to be hard
i'm afraid i'm in the second camp and
i'm not claiming i'm the best but i'm
pretty good and mostly because i know
that i know
this is a beautiful thing and we are
going to learn it
and it's and and we'll be different
after we know it for all time
there's a great antidote to cynicism in
that too because
part of the culture war that's going on
right now is the consequence of an
insistence that the fundamental
motivation of people who are in
positions of authority like you is one
of power and domination so imagine that
there is
there's no
there's almost nothing positive in
abject and dependent subordination
that's pretty bad outcome
and so then you might say
that the ability to use compulsion and
to attain domination
is a higher moral good than abject
subjugation and dependence now i'm not
saying it is but i think you could make
that case
and then you could also make the case
and the postmodern marxist types do this
that that's really the fundamental
motivation of mankind in every
relationship marital relationships
historical relationships business
relationships it's like
the willingness and ability to use
compulsion to manifest power power
and i think well that's probably better
than dependency
but compared to
the pleasure of let's say genuine
friendship or mentorship it's not even
in the same conceptual universe and so
one of the things that the cynics about
business organizations for example don't
understand by emphasizing the role of
power is how much pleasure there is and
this is a paternal pleasure i think a
patriarchal pleasure in the most
fundamental sense
in having the opportunity to find
someone who's rife with potential and to
offer them a multitude of beneficial
pathways forward to be able to
participate in that my graduate
supervisor robert peel great guy still
alive we're going to talk to him on the
podcast soon
he was a great mentor
he had his wheelhouse of authority and
knowledge encyclopedic knowledge of the
relevant psychological literature great
administrator and
great manager of people
and he took immense pleasure in
forming a stable of graduate students
and undergraduates and facilitating
their development forward that was a
primary motivating purpose of his life
and he was
interested in being an author on the
papers and getting credit for his role
all of that but fundamentally he was a
man who got obstacles the hell out of
the way
and enabled
movement forward for those who wanted to
move forward and then there was immense
intrinsic pleasure in that i mean that
was really the
hallmark of his life i went to his fest
shift when he retired with my former
colleagues and it was a lovely affair
there was a hundred people there about
and every single one of them got up and
said
here's the signal manner in which this
man transformed my life
that beats the hell of power
it's not it's not only not power it is
the literal antithesis of power
and not this also not this corrupt
collapsing into an ineffectual
dependency that you might attain by
abdicating all your pretensions to power
i have uh
see
i'll bet when you have that fetch drift
interview yourself you'll have a
thousand there
uh
i have some protesters yeah you'll have
well yeah we both get that right uh i
have
about 30 students who become powerful
people
boys and girls big in the government
and they
are still my student
and when i see them
i don't talk about their power
i talk about their character
uh
and they
and you know they
and you know these are people who can go
and you know
i have equally talented students
who are not at all powerful
and i have the same relationship with
them
and you know that because you get
uh you know there's
i teach
one class a term and i have about 30
students in it which is big for
hillsdale standards but i'm the
president and i don't teach much so i
let more in
uh
and then that means that every year 60 i
get to know in detail
except then we have senior dinner and
all that
and there's
1650 on the campus
that means most of them i don't know
very well
but
in another way i know them all and the
ones i get to know well
i remember
and that means
you see what what
um
it would be a better life than i am
living
to be abraham lincoln
because
he was a beautiful human being
uh
winston churchill same thing
but
to be president just to be president
you and i are leading better lives than
that
and and
you get your mind around i also think
you know there's nothing i've watched
university president sometimes
kowtow
to the mob
and i think
how dismal that must be from the
perspective of
making amends with your own conscience
that you've attained this position of
power
without the requisite moral competence
and then
when the mob comes because
you strive for the position rather than
for the character that would entitle you
in some real sense to the position that
you have to fold in the most ignominious
of ways
and to me that just shows the absolute
hollowness
of the attempt to attain power without
attaining first the authority and the
competence that would make that power
that would render that power justifiable
you know the
the bad thing about authority
i have authority i have a fair amount of
authority
and the bad thing about it is
you're at risk when you use it
but if you use it badly in a way to
protect yourself
you will do harm to other people
and people who don't deserve it
and so somehow you have to
find a way not to do that
and uh that's
you know
i had somebody say to me once uh
so i hear you're a pretty good teacher
and i said i'm okay
and he said you've written some books
and i said i have i've written three he
said i've read one of them it's good
and i said thank you and he said
why do you do this
you know
because
you know to a faculty member the most
sensible ones
my job is a pain in the took us why
would you do it right
and i looked up and i said well
partly because i can so far
i'm made so that i can do this probably
uh
but yeah
i i
it's very possible that when i leave it
you know unless i'm too old
i will
find something better to do right here
in this college because there are better
jobs than mine
and that's you know if you know that
you got to keep yourself from being a
tyrant you know and and it's because
most people don't get to be a grand
tyrant they only get to be a petty
tyrant and how contentful of that but
you know they're wonderful classic books
about
people who
[Music]
are famous
for making people do things they don't
want to do
and it's universal rulers over hell
that's it that's the that's the
accomplishment of untrammeled powers you
get to be the head demon in a chorus of
demons and to me that's the most
cataclysmic failure not a sign of the
success of the psychopathic and
narcissistic
and then
those people are are always presented as
miserable in the classic books in
shakespeare too
uh even if surrounded by babbling sick
of fats yeah and schemers and the and
you and even if your schemes are
successful and not found out
you know you know so yeah you don't
you don't want a life like that
and uh
yeah and maybe you don't want to impose
that on other people either no you don't
you know that's uh
mustn't you mustn't and uh and that
means that
pri it's it's an excellent guide it's
not the only way
proper authority
derives from the will
of the per person over whom it's
exercised
that's the consent of the government if
i remember correctly that's right and
that's and that means that then
you don't have to fight
right we're going to have to do one
thing or another here
and
there are people in favor of both that
means some people are going to be happy
but everybody's given their consent that
we're going to decide this thing this
way
and that's sued honorably that's right
yeah wouldn't that be lovely yeah and
you know we've got to get back to that
it's uh
well i really saw that at hillsdale and
i'm going to talk to dr arn moore behind
the daily wire plus paywall i've decided
to
do a more personal interview with people
for an additional half an hour as part
of my contractual obligations to the
partnership with this arrangement um
with this with this group and so i think
that's a good way of splitting it up
and so well i talked today with dr larry
yarn who's president of hillsdale
college which i think is a remarkable
institution and i think one that's whose
best days are still in front of it which
is quite interesting and which is
offering a proposition which at the
moment has become almost
of almost infinite value which is a
disciplined
stringent strict educational doctrine
voluntarily
undertaken devoted towards the true ends
of a true liberal arts education man and
there's nothing more valuable than that
you know
accepting perhaps like servitude to god
himself and so thank you very much for
talking to me thank you it's going to be
a privilege and a pleasure working with
you as we move forward mine very much
thank you
hello everyone i would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com